-Welcome back to "Late Night."
In a couple of months,
Kamala Harris will become
the first female Vice Presiden
of the United States.
And women everywhere --
-[Flatly]
Wow. Kamala Harris.
Another thing to add
to her list of accomplishments
-Um, sorry, everybody.
This is one of our writers
Dina Gusovsky.
Dina, why are you not excite
about Kamala Harris?
Is it because you're not a fan
of her policy positions?
-No.
-Is it because it's ridiculous
we have never had a female vic
president, let alone president
-Not really.
-So, then, what is it?
-All right. Fine.
I'm just jealous, okay?
-Well, there's no need
to be jealous.
I mean, you could run for office
one day, too, and...
-How come Kamala Harris found
Jewish man to marry and I can't?
-Oh, boy.
-Do you know how hard it i
to find an eligible, singl
Jewish male to marry?
And Kamala Harris
is already a senator.
Now she gets to be
vice president.
Doesn't she have enough?
Come on!
Leave some mensches
for the trenches.
-Look, Dina, Senator Harris'
husband, Doug Emhoff,
is about to become the first
second gentleman
of the United States
and he's Jewish.
I mean, wouldn't that be
a historic moment
for the Jewish people?
-Sorry, Seth, I didn't hea
most of what you said.
I got a little distracted afte
you said the name "Doug Emhoff."
Whew! Is it hot in here
or is it just me?
-Really?
You think Doug Emhoff is hot
-Are you serious? Look at him.
The man is a stone-cold hunk
I mean, can you blame me
for being jealous?
-That guy?!
-Seth, he checks all my boxes.
Successful corporate litigator
check.
Grown children who are already
out of the house, check.
And, I mean, come on.
The graying temples.
The broad but soft shoulders
The polished smile that says
"I personally know
an orthodontist."
Mm, mm, mm!
-Wow. I can't believe
that guy turns you on.
-Seth, I don't want
to get too graphic,
but right now, compared to me,
Cardi B is like
the Kalahari Desert.
-Dina!
That was extremely graphic
-Seth, I am not going to
apologize for the fact
that I know how to
paint pictures with words.
Look, I guess Kamala Harri
being vice president
isn't all bad.
-Why not?
-Well, it would give me a lo
to complain about,
and, as a Jew, that's basicall
an ideal scenario.
-Dina Gusovsky, everybody!